Eh bah j'crois que c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire, ah oui y a un petit let's play qui arrivera dans 2 semaines.
Premier épisode qui sortira le 5 décembre (5 décembre, répété 2 fois)
Nous sommes le 5 décembre et tu es très intelligent !
Tu te doutes donc, de ce qui va se passer...
NOUVEAU LET'S PLAY ! C'EST LA FIESTA MON POTE !
Ca faisait longtemps !
J'suis hyper putain de content, ça fait super longtemps que j'attends de jouer à ce jeu,
Et pourtant j'avais pas joué au premier.
C'est The Last Guardian, voilà.
Fait par les mecs qui avaient fait Shadow of Colossus un jeu qui avait fait un buzz de malade !
Et pourtant je n'y avais pas joué chui une grosse merde !
Cette fois-ci on fait un let's play sur un jeu très poétique.
Très...
Ensorcellant...
Qui parle du péril d'un petit garçon et d'une bête qui s'appelle Trico
Ter...
Tricoter fallait la faire comme ça on la fait plus !
C'est parti !
Réveille-toi gamin.
Titouan y a école ton réveil n'a pas sonné.
Whaow...
Allez lève-toi gamin !
C'est trop cool que ce soit en VO (Version Originale audio d'un jeu vidéo), c'est super cool !
J'adore le japonais !
Très bonne question.
Who who who who !
Cours ! Cours ! Cours !
Il est accroché, il est accroché mais fait gaffe quand même !
Si ça se trouve il faut que j'm'approche, il va pas me bouffer ce serait nawak
Oh elle a un truc planté !
Meerde...
C'est plutôt les hommes qui sont mangeurs de bêtes au final c'est ça...
Il faut que je le retire, elle va me démolir mais il faut que je le retire, c'est pour ton bien.
Allez !
Allez allez on y va on y va on y va Trico !
Ca va être rapide ça va être rapide !
Ah j'suis désolé...
J'suis désolé...
Pardon...
Oh elle est super violente Trico !
J'me réveille il aura réussi à se libérer vous pensez ?
Oui il va renaître dans sa caverne le Trico
On se le demande.
Oh putain !
Y a 18 heures qui sont passées.
Bon alors du coup est-ce qu'il va me laisser approcher en fait faut que je le libère à mon avis...
Euh...
Ouais il tient plus debout le pauvre...
Putaaain...
Euuuuuh...
Les bidons là-haut peut-être que c'est de la nourriture ? Nan ? Rien à voir ? On va aller voir !
Hop,
Ca c'est pas de la bouffe ?
Meeeerde !
Si c'est de la bouffe, j'vais lui amener, j'vais lui amener.
J'pense que c'est de la bouffe.
Saisir avec "la touche O de la manette"
Allez vas-y amène lui !
Nan, j'vais...
Tiens !
*rires*
Pardon pour le manque de respect !
Et c'est pas moi qu'il doit manger attention !
Ouais, elle est méfiante parce qu'elle souffre... parce que, c'est pas éto...
Euuuuh...
Si on fait le point,
Là y a un levier.
Ca doit ouvrir quelque chose ça à mon avis.
*Grincement d'une porte s'ouvrant lentement*
On rentre dans la cage et on trouve... un bidon...
bah le même que tout à l'heure ouais...
Peut être que là c'est de la meilleure bouffe je sais pas....
Et on va le lui déposer à ses pieds...
Ah mais il l'a mangé ou pas là? il est plus là le bidon...
Il l'a mangé je pense....
Ah! pardon... Bon bah tiens... * rire *
PRENDS LE BIDON!
Ah là haut y a un bidon mais je peux pas...
Ah si y a un petit trou si je peux y accéder... ok!
Faut que je l'amène
Vooooiiiiiiiiilà!
Je vais lui amener le dernier bidon et on va voir s'il bouffe...
Tiens mon pote!
Ah mais arrêteeeuuuuu!
Il est terrible hein!
Il mange ou pas du coup?
Il les mange à chaque fois je crois hein?
Aaaah... voilà
ça fais du bien mon grand?
Bah oui!
Il arrive à se lever maintenant?
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaah....
Comment je fais ?
Comment je vais faire...
Ah! son collier je pense... y a un truc à détacher?
Tu... Je t'ai donné à bouffer, tu me tolères maintenant ou pas ?
Ou tu me tolères pas ?
Faut que j'aille de long de ton collier mon grand
Laisse, laisse moi, laisse moi  !
Panique pas !
Laisse moi juste regarder vers ton collier
J'vais l'dégager ce pieu!
Allez courage, courage! Tu vas avoir mal un coup sec, ça va aller!
C'est bon ça va!
Oh non, j'vais pas m'évanouir 18 heures encore!
Oh remarque il doit faire des bonnes nuits lui! Ca doit être facile de s'endormir avec Trico!
Ooooh!
Il le sniffe, il s'en veut... Il doit s'en vouloir!
Même nous on a ce côté un peu, quand on nous fait mal on a envie de frapper un truc quoi...
C'est insoutenable!
Bah oui mon grand!
Tu me tolères maintenant, ça va?
"Appeler Trico"
Donc si j'bouge et qu'j'l'appelle, il va venir!
Si j'vais là et qu'je l'appelle il vient!
Ouiiii!
Trop cooool!
Ouah il est immeeeeense!
C'est ouf mon gars!
Il est totalement immense!
J'pense que le mieux en vrai c'est d'monter dessus en allant sur la chaîne
Oh oui c'est bon!
Vas-y, j'arrive, j'arrive, j'arrive, j'arrive!
Là y a un le... y a un truc à tirer là!
Voilà c'est ça! Ca l'a libéré?
Mais il va se barrer et fin du jeu quoi!
Bah oui mon grand!
Aaah ça fait du bien au cou hein
AAAAH!
Pourquoi!
Ok il s'est débarrassé,
maintenant il est complètement libéré et en pleine forme!
Hein mon grand?
*Cri de surprise*
Wouah!
Ah c'est trop cooool!
Ah d'la bouffe! Tu veux de la bouffe?
Ah j'suppose qu'il faut que j'aille là-haut et qu'je passe de l'autre côté, on va se rejoindre, c'est ça mon grand?
T'as pas mal quand j'tire sur tes plumes comme ça?
C'est quand même un gros manque de respect!
Ah c'est bon! C'est passé!
Bah voilà! J'ai shooté dedans, j'suis pas du tout respectueux!
Tiens y en a là aussi s'tu veux!
Voilà! Ca c'est pour toi, c'est gratuit!
Alors, j'vais passer de l'autre côté et on va se rejoindre j'pense
Alors, où ça va nous mener?
Est-ce qu'on va pas tomber sur des grandes étendues
très très belles bien ensoleillées?
Non! C'est la grotte sombre et humide!
*Rire de fdp*
Ah bah y a une chance sur deux hein!  Je me demande ou il va me rejoindre...
Et s'il est vraiment gentil ou si euh...
Je vais devoir faire d'autres trucs en plus
avant qu'il soit vraiment bien gentil bien docile
Je pense qu'il ne sera jamais vraiment docile en faite...
Wouaaah c'est quoi ça...
Oooooh...
Qu'est ce que c'est que ça mon gars...
Bon bah avançons hein! Qu'est ce qu'on a ici?
On dirait qu'on peut utiliser ça
"Saisir" ah ouais! Ca se retire!
Ok
C'est une lumière?
"Ce miroir et sa mystérieuse lueur" ouais effectivement
Tu peux dire que tu l'as volé mon gars!
J'pense qu'y a un truc à illuminer, à priori j'dirais
que c'est l'eau?
C'est faux! C'est faux, euuuuh, voilà!
Ah mais, ça se trouve faut qu'j'revienne là où j'étais au début en fait, j'me dis... Tout simplement
Oh tu dormaiiiis!
*rire* Tu faisais un p'tit somme!
Tranquillement!
Alors, montre-moi, Trico, où j'dois mettre ça!
Ah ça va pas l'faire flipper, si ça se trouve il vaaa...
Oh nooon!
On dirait qu'ça change euuuuh...
Trico
Si j'fais ça? Non?
What the fuuuck! Il s'est passé quoi là?
*rire* Moi aussi!
Ben très bonne question!
Peut-être hein!
Ben j'crois qu'c'est ça hein!
Bon Trico on fait quoi du coup? On bouge ou oooonn...
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
A mon avis faut lui remonter dessus!
Hop! Hop! Hop! Hop! Hop!
Vas-y guide-moi!
Guide-moi Trico, j'sais pas où il faut aller là dans l'jeu!
Il nous remmène de l'autre côté
Va y avoir un truc à faire avec le miroir là-bas
Là il va falloir que je montre, euh peut-être, une direction avec le miroir?
Et ça va leeeeee, l'attirer?
Ah en face là-bas! Ca a pas l'air solide, ouais!
Ouais ben essayons!
Vas-y fait! Fais-nous rêver!
Parfait çaaaa!
Merci Trico!
Eh bien allons-y, avançons!
Avançons gamin!
Il veut pas avancer!
C'est lui qui fait 28 mètres de long et c'est moi qui doit entrer en premier, c'est ça?
Ok! Allez, j'y vais, j'y vais, j'y vais! J'ai compris, j'y vais!
Il m'suis en fait, c'est ça?
Bon fait attention où tu marches Trico, tu peux m'écraser en une seconde!
Ouaiiis elle a pas l'air très mangeuse d'hommes quand même cette bête!
Si elle l'avait été, j'pense qu'elle m'aurait bouffé quand elle était au plus mal hein!
Ou alors elle est vraiment très gentille!
Elle a un capital sympathie assez ouf!
Tu t'en sors Trico?
Ca va pour toi?
C'est un peu dur hein...
Ca va aller mon grand!
Ah moi j'suis très faible avec les animaux! J'avoue, j'suis très gaga!
Ah j'ai mes deux chats! J'ai Jumbo et Lua et...
C'est pour ça que je voulais vraiment faire "The Last Guardians"
J'me doutais que la relation entre le petit et la bête allait être très très touchante
et allait très bien m'atteindre!
Alors! On saute dans l'eau?
C'est parti, notre premier Aquaboulevard ensemble, c'est incroyable!
Putain, j'ai cru qu'il y avait pas de profondeur!
Tu sautes ou pas?
Il veut pas s'mouiller?
Allez viens!
Viens mon grand, regarde moi j'suis déjà là!
Tu viens?
C'est sa faiblesse, c'est l'eau?
Ouais c'est ça! C'est sa faiblesse je pense!
Et là il fait une grosse boum (bombe) qui vide carrément l'eau de la salle!
Bon j'vais aller là-bas!
Y a des marches, ça m'intéresse...
Ah mais non! Là-bas y a une espèce de palissade que je vais devoir casser avec le...
Avec Trico, donc première énigme!
Comment faire entrer Trico sans qu'il touche l'eau?
Parce qu'apparemment il aime pas du tout l'eau!
Là j'vais l'amener, j'vais l'appeler ici!
Viens là, fais l'tour!
Fais l'tour, sois pas con!
Oh c'est horrible, on voit qu'il a envie de me suivre, qu'il m'aime déjà!
Mais qu'il a vraiment trop peur de l'eau!
Est-ce que ça marche à distance son rayon?
Ah ouais d'accord!
Il l'envoie vraiment là où je pointe le miroir!
Bon ben mon grand!
J'vais aller de l'autre côté, puis tu vas me suivre!
Puis tu vas me sécher en me soufflant dessus aussi!
Alors!
On va passer, et on va l'appeler!
Non?
Non! Bon! Alors!
Y a ça, faut qu'je monte via ça j'suppose? Ouais! C'est ça
Donc là y a un nouvel objet... Faut qu'je prenne ça?
C'est... C'est un objet?
Et qu'je l'p...
Ah ouais d'accord!
On part sur un biceps négatif de la part de cet enfant!
Alors, à mon avis, faut plutôt que je le pousse...
Ouais voilà!
GNA!
Ah c'est de la bouffe? Et donc ça va l'attirer?
On va convaincre sa peur par la bouffe! (ça veut rien dire!)
Y a de la bouffe en bas!
Ah il l'a...
*Rire*
C'est drôle putain! C'est vraiment comme un chat ou un chien quoi!
Allez ramène tes plumes! On s'casse!
Il nous amène... Il est intrigué par un endroit... Ah il va me permettre d'atteindre cette montée, c'est ça?
Merci Trico!
Donc il viens de sauter, il nous a amené là!
On est au top là!
Ah j'vais avoir besoin de toi pour atteindre le trou qui est là-haut par contre!
Ah j'suis désolé de te tirer les plumes mon gars!
A la fin du jeu t'auras plus aucune plume!
Ah non ok! Faut qu'j'escalade via ce rebord-là, ok j'ai compris!
Eh ben c'est foiré! C'est foiré, merci Trico!
Euh peut-être par là du coup, ouais c'est ça ok, je dois escalader par moi-même
Ok on est dans le trou!
Noooon! Pourquoi?
Mais il nous brise le coeur cet enfant là!
Mais non!
Oh mec!
C'est horrible j'me suis déjà attaché a cette petite bête !
'Fin..
Petite tranquille
Mais naaaaan
Waaaaaa..
C'est très très beau.
'Tain! Les musiques mon gars, les musiques !
Il fait son petit cri il est content d'avoir retrouvé la liberté
Je pense qu'il faut longer le mur qu'il y a là
Ca doit etre le chemin à mon avis
Ouais, ouais c'est ça ouais
Waaaaaa, c'est tenduuuu, lui aussi il marche de manière tendue, il me tend encore plus avec sa démarche quoi
Arrête !
Ah ! Je pense qu'il va falloir s'aider de la chaîne bientôt... Ouais y'a un trou
Je devine tout aujourd'hui! J'ai l'impression d'être un génie! Alors que non!
C'est juste que c'est euuuh... assez instinctif!
Il m'suis?!
Gneuuu! Fait attention mec!
*rire*
Il est debout sur ses pierres!
Fait attention à toi! C'est pas très stable!
Il a l'agilité du chat!
Bon, on a atteint l'autre côté!
Trico nous a suivi jusqu'au bout, j'espèèère!
Il est où? Ok il continue...
C'est pas très stable hein!
T'es bien serein je trouve!
On va où Trico ici?
On va avoir besoin de toi j'crois!
Là j'vais te monter dessus et tu vas m'aider!
Allez on y va mon gars!
Tu sais ce que t'as à faire! Tu le sais, je n'ai pas besoin de t'le dire!
Ah ben non, attends, faut péter la porte là!
Allez pète-moi ça!
Merciii!
Merde...
On s'est foiré là!
Ah non c'est bon!
Ah non... J'croyais qu'ça faisait un pont, mais...
Ah ben si, c'est bon!
Ok on va y aller! Attends qu'je passe Trico s'il te plaît
parce que toi si ça pète, j'aimerais pas tomber dans le vide avec toi!
J'aimerai pas que tu tombes non plus, mais bon
Il est très serein, hein
J'ai beaucoup de respect envers cet animal
On continue
On arrive dans une nouvelle place !
Je crois qu'il faut aller toujours tout droit.
Ah non la grille a l'air fermée !
Est-ce qu'on peut l'ouvrir d'ici ?
Non
Non, elle est bien fermée.
Il est coincé ?
Oh non, il peut mettre que sa tête.
Attend j'arrive Tritri !
On va monter, on va voir si y a pas moyen déjà de choper Trico et tout sinon puisque sinon on va vraiment être dans le caca
Vas-y viens là. On va l'appeler.
Alors il vient, est-ce qu'il va sauter ?
Vas-y viens, avec tes p'tites ailes.
Ouaaaais.
Yes mon pote !
T'ain je pensais même qu'il allait pouvoir !
On y est mon grand ! Allez trouvons la sortie.
Si tu me fais monter la-dessus.
Moi je peux sauter, m'accrocher là.
Et accéder à ce morceau là de balcon.
Hein.
Yes.
Merci mon gars.
Alors où ça va nous mener ?
Oh non nul part ! Oh la loose.
Ah mais mecs c'est ça en fait.
Attend, je vais devoir te resauter dessus. Tu le prends pas mal.
Ok merci !
Voilà.
Il va falloir que j'escalade ce truc là.
Ouais voilà comme ça, ouais, non c'est bon regarde comme ça j'ai atteins ça , y a une chaine là-bas ok.
On y va.
Hop, ok.
T'ain on monte super haut là.
Ok on atterrit là.
Ok on va là.
Nouveau chemin.
En hauteur, Trico il peut pas nous suivre, on est très triste.
Mais je pense qu'on va le retrouver juste après.
Ah de la bouffe ?!
Ah bah j'vais l'attirer en fait.
Je pense qu'il y a certain endroit à mon avis. La mécanique c'est qu'à certains endroits auxquels il a accès que quand tu mets de la bouffe.
Comme l'eau tout à l'heure sinon il veut pas y aller, il dit "Oulala non non pas de bouffe j'suis pas là."
Beh mon grand !
Mais depuis quand tu me suis comme ça ?
Bon bah tiens, mets toi bien !
Ah bah voilà tu nous a fait des frayeurs.
On a cru que t'avais déjà perdu l'appétit.
Hop, hop on y va.
Nice !
Merci Trico.
Hiii Paaaa Pooouuu on passe la porte.
Et y a une autre porte, que cette fois
il ne peut pas casser, merde.
Comment je fais ?
Ah là y a un trou.
Ok
Donc ça c'est clairement la mécanique de gameplay de ce jeu en gros.
L'enfant a accès à certains endroits où Trico n'a pas accès et le but c'est de
Wah c'est beau.
C'est beau.
Comme c'est beau.
Il a escaladé ?
Tu pari combien ?
*rire*
T'es incroyable Trico hein.
T'es *étonnement*.. C'est bon ça va, tout va bien.
T'es incroyable mon grand hein ? Tu me colles hein, tu me lâches plus.
On est meilleur pote maintenant toi et moi.
Woh.
C'est immense, y a des environnements immenses quoi. Comme Shadow Of Colossus.
Ah ouais y a le pont et tout là-haut y a la tour.
J'pense qu'il va falloir gagner en hauteur à un moment donné mais j'sais pas trop quand.
Qu'est-ce t'en penses Trico t'es d'accord avec moi ou pas ?
Hééé.
Tu m'attends pas ?
T'es comme ça toi ? Et il s'en bat les couilles.
Mais attend moi !
Je suppose que j'aurais dû être sur ton dos quand t'as fais ça ?
Allez reviens, reviens on va refaire ça.
Ok désolé mec hein j't'ai fais faire un aller-retour pour rien mais tu m'as pas prévenu.
Faut que tu me préviennes mon p'tit Trico.
Oh non non je veux vraiment pas être sous ton ventre quand tu vas faire ça.
Je vais lâcher prise c'est sûr.
Ahhhhhh
Il m'a retourné le cerveau.
J'suis posey.
Entre le mur et tes plumes, posey.
Ok on est bon.
Alors nous voilà de l'autre côté du mur de la
Oh c'est quoi ça ?
Oh
C'est nouveau ça ?
Euh.
C'est peut être pas ce qu'il fallait que je fasse.
Oh mais il est mignon ! Il est mignon. On va devenir gaga.
Et je le caresse. Il est trop adorable ce Trico.
Allez viens mon grand.
De grandes aventures nous attendent toi et moi.
On gagne en hauteur. Mais c'est le but je pense, le but c'est d'atteindre cette fameuse tour donc de gagner le plus possible en hauteur.
Ok on arrive en haut.
Haha il colle son front à la pierre froide le pauvre.
Hiyaa
Au top.
Non mais là le petit prend des risque assez ouf.
Non..Woh.
Arrêtez de jouer avec mon coeur.
Niiiice.
On lâche la prise et on y est.
T'inquiètes, t'inquiètes, je vais trouver le levier, je vais trouver le levier t'en fais pas.
Il est juste là t'en fais pas.
Parfait
Viens par ici mon ami !
Tiens mon gars.
En plein vol. Oh j'suis fier, c'est comme si c'était les premiers pas de mon bébé.
Allez on continue.
Ah je vais avoir besoin de toi mon grand.
Allez tu me fais le plaisir de péter ça.
Nickel.
Woh.
Ah on commence à monter. On est dans la tour là ?
Ouais.
On est bon là.
T'as peur de quoi ? T'as peur de quoi Trico ?
Bon bah j'y vais hein.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a Trico!
Tranquille.
De quoi t'as peur Trico j'comprends pas.
Qu'est-ce tu nous fais là?
C'est ce truc là en-dessous lui qui lui fait peur. Mais je sais pas ce que c'est.
J'suis sûr que c'est un truc qu'on qui envoie de l'électricité ou..
Ah c'est un truc pour les capturer.
Oh non.
Qu'est-ce que je dois faire ?
Woh.
Ah merde ça le met en mode violent c'est ça ?
Ca le rend méchant.
C'est ça ?
Oh !
Han !
Ca le rend méchant.
Donc en fait là ces bêtes qui tuent les hommes non ! A la base elles tuent pas les hommes.
C'est les hommes qui les ont rendu comme ça en utilisant ces instruments.
Et je me demande si c'était prévu ou pas que je me fasse manger là.
Je me re-réveille.
J'suis avec Trico qui lui maintenant dors.
Eh bah !
Merde c'est vrai ça.
Euh.
Mais comment je fais du coup ? J'espère que j'en aurais plus besoin pour l'instant.
Putain. Il a l'air HS.. Ah il a saigné aussi hein.
Bon j'peux quand même lui monter dessus quand il est mal.
Bon je sais pas si c'est cool de ma part, mais je voulais juste vérifier.
Peut être que de là où il est, il me permettait d'accéder à un truc en fait.
AH ! Regarde sa queue elle pend.
Mec ça se trouve y a un truc à faire attend.
Attend si j'ai trouvé ça, c'est exceptionnel.
Putain j'suis fier.
Ah c'est là qu'il faut aller ! Putain. C'est bien pensé mec c'est ouf.
Y a un passage dans le mur ou pas ?
Ouais.
Du coup je suis sous la passerelle.
Qu'est-ce qui y a ?
C'est quoi ça ?
Ah bah ouais.
C'est quoi ces armures ? Aux yeux Iron man là ?
On arrive oh on arrive au bout du tunnel (en chantant)
J'avais envie de le dire en chantant parce que là j'ai un peu la pression.
Avec ce qu'il vient de se passer.
Bon on monte cette échelle.
Ah ! Un levier.
Ok.
Hop.
Bon faut que je ramène Trico.
Eh il est mort. Il est HS.
Bon bah mec y a pas le choix hein.
Faut que j'y aille sans lui.
Et au pire les armures elles vont me niquer ma mère.
Elles vont me buter c'est sûr.
Sinon, il l'aurait jamais dit j'aurais préféré les éviter.
Moi là je les évite pas je vais devant.
Euuuuuh
*cri*
Lâchez-moi !
Ok faut que j'y aille. Ok je pense je vais les attirer vers Trico.
Ca va peut-être le réveiller.
On va tenter cette strat les gars !
Trico mec j'ai besoin toi de ouf. J'ai besoin de toi de ouf.
Ah
Ca le réveille
Oh ouais on a choisi la bonne stratégie.
*rire*
Ca fait moins les malins hein, quand mon meilleur ami est là.
Fait les tomber du pont.
Pousse les un par un.
Vooooilà.
Très très bien. Bravo mon grand.
C'est bien !
Aïe.
Caresser Trico. Ah faut juste que je le caresse.
Je le caresse. Je le caresse. Je le caresse.
D'accord c'est juste ça la manière dont je dois le calmer.
Ca va.
Bah mon grand, tu nous a fais une phase là hein.
Je sais pas ce qu'elles font ces lumières bleues mais elles t'ont mis mal.
Allez ça caresse. Ça caresse. Ça caresse, ça fait du plaisir.
C'est bon. Il va mieux.
Eh bien voilà les amis c'est la fin de ce premier épisode sur The Last Guardian.
J'espère que ça vous a plu.
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo comme d'habitude plus que jamais.
J'espère vraiment que ça va vous plaire parce que c'est un engagement de faire un let's play, on sait jamais si ça va trop plaire.
Et on s'engage a faire dix vidéos sur le jeu quand même.
Je terminerai le jeu quoi qu'il arrive.
Je vais pas le commencer, et l'arrêter si ça ne plait pas.
Donc j'espère que ça vous plait.
Moi en tout cas, ça me plaît.
Et c'est l'important.
Puisque sinon.. Euh, putain on serait mal barré.
Là je suis très sensible à ces jeux comme ça autour de l'amitié.
Surtout que là en plus c'est un animal et j'adore les animaux.
Je vous dis à très bientôt, pour le prochain épisode.
Je pense que je mettrais en ligne des épisodes tout les deux jours.
Voilà même si ça tombe sur un jour où je mets en ligne une vidéo habituellement.
Lundi, Mardi, Mercredi ou Vendredi.
Eh bien c'est pas grave y aura deux vidéos.
Y aura l'épisode du let's play plus la vidéo normale.
Après je vous balance ça comme ça.
Ca se trouve, j'en mettrais pas quelquefois pendant trois jours.
J'en sais rien, mais j'essayerais d'en publier aussi souvent que possible.
Et je pense que, au total le solo fait quinze heures.
Vu que je joue une heure et demie par vidéo on en a pour dix vidéos, merci Jean-Michel Math.
Allez on se retrouve pour une prochaine vidéo. Merci d'avoir regardé porter vous bien, ciao tout le monde.
Peace.